Amsterdam is hands-down Europe's capital
of bicycle riders it's home to an
estimated nine hundred thousand bikes
that's more than the population of the
city center in 2001 the world's first
bicycle parking garage was built at the
city's central rail station
Sean Cody has been offering individual
sightseeing tours of the capital with
his company Joyride tours for the past
seven years naturally by bike for me one
of the most interesting things about
Amsterdam isn't just the beautiful city
but it's also the citizens that make up
the city it's people from all over the
world and it actually just beat out New
York as having the most variety of
nationalities in any city in the world
you know it's also very small City so I
find it quite enjoyable that it's only
about 1.6 million with the suburbs maybe
800,000 the city center so you get this
international city feel but you're in a
very small liveable enjoyable city many
of Cody's tours start off at Dam Square
the birthplace of Amsterdam in the 13th
century local fishermen dammed the river
Amstel and settled in a village they
called Amsterdam
the square is also home to the 17th
century royal palace this was not a
royal palace this was the mayor's office
in Amsterdam and if you look at it
that's why it's not an impressive
building if you compare it to Versailles
or Windsor Castle it's not impressive at
all but originally this was the largest
Civic building in Europe and it
celebrated the power of the Republic in
the 17th century Amsterdam rose to
become a key center of international
trade amassing unimaginable this is when
the world-famous Canal ring area was
developed swampland was drained using a
system of 165 canals and concentric arcs
today the urban ensemble is a unesco
world heritage site often the houses
along the canals were commissioned by
wealthy merchants many were Calvinists
which is why the houses are modest in
design wealth was displayed in more
subtle ways this black house here is a
good indication of that it's a very thin
house it's quite tall and if you look at
the glass on it compared to the house
right behind me you'll see it's got very
large windows this was a way of showing
the wealth on the old days Amsterdam
boasts no fewer than 44 museums
one is the van Gogh Museum it houses a
collection of 200 works by the Dutch
artist
another must-see is the heights Museum
the National Museum of the Netherlands
it was already a traffic friendly
building when it opened in 1885 and
today it could well be the only museum
that you can ride a bike through it
holds works by Dutch Golden Age masters
like Fumiya
and Rembrandt the Rijksmuseum is built
around the 1800s and it's designed by a
gentleman by the name of Pierre CalPERS
and if you arrived in Amsterdam by train
and you see the central train station
it's actually designed by the same
architect actually so that's why they
looked very similar in design one of
Amsterdam's top tourist destinations
lies on the Princeton cast the end frank
house every day long lines form outside
the museum in 2016 it attracted almost
1.3 million visitors this is where the
13 year old Jewish girl and Frank went
into hiding with their family during
World War 2 to escape the Nazis and
where she wrote her world-famous diary a
tour of the secret annex conveys the
claustrophobic conditions of the hiding
place the rooms are unfurnished but
there's an exhibit of personal objects
that belonged to the people who hid here
onward by bike through Amsterdam the
Netherlands are famous for their
cheese's so the next stop on our tour is
one of the many cheese shops in the city
cos heist Trump has all the classics on
offer
among them Gouda Emmentaler and a pencil
on the soil in the Netherlands is very
very hard you say you can it's very good
for growing really fine dress so keeping
cows is really a thing for the Dutch and
cows they give a lot of milk of course
and from that milk they make the cheese
we make a lot of cheese we eat a lot of
cheese the Dutch are in average the
tallest people of the planet and as the
myth is that that's because they eat a
lot of cheese
show and Kody's tour ends at a more
recently installed landmark the giant I
am stirred am marketing logo is a
popular photo op for visitors and one
that captures the inclusive spirit of
this open city